y'a tout le monde s'excuse et
aujourd'hui on se retrouve sur pizza
jerry baril aujourd'hui nous sommes des
livreurs de pizza comme pizza à
l'épisode tout ça mais je pense qu'il
est un peu plus glauque
il est tard vous avez vous approché la
dernière absolument on n'a rien vu ok
bon en gros de lehman pizza pizza paï
met à votre service
donc on se doute bien que cette petite
maison va être bien glauque ça c'est
absolument évident quel genre de
personne livre une maison avec un
portail de pommettes avec un labyrinthe
squat bruit c'est michael jackson ok
j'étais j'ai sonné sa réussite et non
mais tu vas que ça va tourner qui sait
pizzas livrées aux cantons please wait
inside à will get smart forum se tient
comme line mes fesses tu vas me violer
dans un coin moi car eux sont très
mauvais alors c'est quoi une fausse un
jeu vous m'avez conseillers avec le
hashtag jeu pour se loger sur twitter tu
vois sur twitter et provisions et déjà
ce feu n'existe pas excellent bon choix
qui sont faits en attend c'est ça better
place de pizzas times en votant pour moi
la xac briennon qui bouge tout seul
c'est une ombre entre banques vous êtes
sérieux
oh non pas ça au nom jacques hétu remet
le courant la salle je me situe en plus
toute seule chez moi devenait retard des
vingt sept à feu
ok bon au même moment puisqu'il ya
quelqu'un là haut à l'eau s'il vous
plaît aidez moi pourquoi il peut dans la
maison c'est du 100 d'accord donc tout
va bien du sang traverse le parc et du
haut mais tout va bien
marchisio autrement appelée plafond
eastwood jack okechukwu y aller parce
qu'il fait noir donc dans ta maison le
soir tôt possible qu'entre reste une
pièce el fitr au noir je m'appelle aux
toilettes
bah merde parfait on a une bougie et
voit le budget sur la carte bleue de
bakar donnez moi mon cash à auch it hot
chip ça sent mauvais ok on va te fait
savoir la maison
agota gars de phoques à leurs pieds
à
[ __ ] de mardi pendu au plafond ok je
me cache ma case
je me casse non
ce pizza
au mondial nous avons aujourd'hui le
scénario le plus à droite du monde kevin
hall fortune via un portail qui vibre du
sang qui coule mais c'est quoi ces jeux
mais [ __ ] de merde on vienne et justes
libres et une pizza on se retrouve avec
une poupée on entend plein front du sang
qui coulait la maison la plus vide du
monde ça c'est une pièce ont des marges
qui ne sert à rien bon en plus on est
médecin
[Musique]
dimanche à la main
car je te fais la bise mais sa voix
tellement cacher je me dis bon ok le
portable
oh non je crois
garder le sens de perverti si vous
regardiez alors qu visite là quelqu'un
help i'm trapel india ou stockées dans
tous les cas nous appelle à aller dans
la maison
white house qui es tu ou et annie get me
foucard offrir aux présentes on se plaît
what they came down up and coming out of
the abyss et le couple 9 secondes du
buzzer max payne shaw cole and head
ok donc il a dit que la lettre là dans
quelques secondes sauf que l'autre n'a
pas eu le temps de lui dire où elle
était elle doit être
une voiture des rares chanteurs noirs là
c'est bon je sais que c'est tout est
bloqué [ __ ] c'est vrai que je me suis
tue c'est le pire ok on redescend au
modèle hybride est myope with any which
is dead watts mais c'est quoi ces
journées [ __ ] pourquoi les explosifs
on parle d'une poupée volant rotary ou
not calling scoop ce surplus lui somme
ouvre la porte
je peux passer fermé dû arriver l'autre
au bras les symptômes et yoann avant
tout besoin de calme et à la john tong
hon rigole les soixante et un bisou
sinon je renonce du michael jackson
autant dire que tu vas avoir peur ok
there will be avec et obtient en deux
chefs ghoga 800 gaye merci l'homme
inconnu
ok donc sur le chase j'ai pas du tout ce
que c'est le chilien comme ça au bst est
en tout cas il m'a dit
au petit musée glock s'est mise en route
oh [ __ ] n'ont par contre là c'est un
peu un peu trop peu un peu trop un peu
trop ça fait peur voilà series nokia
elle est où la clé une sérieuse war is
the key ou la clé s'il vous plaît mettez
quelqu'un dans cette [ __ ] de maison
qui céline de yatuu ferment c'est quoi
ce délire là ok la clé elle mais [ __ ]
et d'un revêtement kaiser hockey ou la
clé répondrai excuse moi il ya une clé
au no pizzeria sont mortes est tuée la
bombe bon voilà on ne peut rien faire
absolument rien un bon s'il vous plaît
bordel mais je veux dire une [ __ ]
franchement je ne veux plus de venir les
voir de pizzas sur deux questions
j'ai peur désormais j'ai peur wafa
qu'est ce qu'il ya est-ce clair bakar
ouhlala tu t'es fait ouhlala une jambe
en l'air et et on ne paie 2010 si tu
ranges cette jambe a sinon je te cram
bon elle il n'y a toujours pas de calais
finalement bon à peut-être là n'ont
toujours pas mais c'est quoi le chase
pourquoi je suis né en anglais je
regrette profondément mais là n'est ce
pas en fait et on passe notre temps à
faire des oh et des ah les eaux et des
sols en bas on ne peut pas sortir moi la
faim quant aux [ __ ] ok qu'est ce
qu'on fait on brûle allez on brûle
[Musique]
le téléphone parce que moi je tente en
plein brûlures yes m'a fait peur ce qu
bordel on est on est au pays des poupées
violente folle aux pièces yes to follow
les pizzas
pourquoi vous faites des jeux comme ça
pourquoi des jeux comme ça existe sur
cette planète bordel or les espèces
d'esprit on doit sur autant dans quel
fou rire on suit les pas de pizza est ce
que le petit poucet a fait son chemin
avec des parts de pizza un donut et
plein de trucs dégueulasses va envoyer
n'importe quoi bon alors on suit les
parts de pizza de merde hein à pizza
fromage là bas ah non je pratiquais
d'accord donc tout va bien à part ça
tout est tout à fait normal dans ce jeu
ok à des des hommes géant
[Applaudissements]
aussi
ouais tu veux ou tu m'a amené la baci
pizza et c'est la fin six lots playing
alors nous venons de jouer au jeu rien
de moins de sens de la planète terre
bornet ok moi je vais faire un jeu avec
un verre ensuite faudra un verre rempli
je dois m'en mettre plein dessus je vais
voir ma vie oh
mes chers frères et soeurs nous sommes
aujourd'hui comme une merde moi tous les
moyens
[Musique]